hi everyone welcome to another live
stream of language design heading for
version 13.1 of awesome language least i
think many of the things we're talking
about here today will be in version 13.1
um but this is part of our incremental
language development series
are we going to start on the first item
here or the second item here
uh let's start with a second uh for now
there's a handful of things related to
tree labeling and styling uh that we
wanted to look at that are for 13.
okay
all right
where do i start
uh you could just go down the list
so
one question is why is this different
from graphs and you've explained some of
that
so tree element label style well let's
see let's start off with tree element
label
there is a tree element label right
yes uh added in 13-0
okay so let's let me just understand
that so if i have a random tree
of 40 elements
um
then i can say
of this tree this
uh tree element label
let's see if i know how to do this
arrow
x blank
let's say x greater than 10
um
arrow
i don't know
framed of x
and is this going to do what i think
splatteroo
right so
the the rules currently don't support
patterns but if they did
the left hand side is a position spec
for trees
so that's one difference with graphs
where the left hand side is a vertex
name
okay
well so if i say
so so what's happening here is you just
specified the label for the root
okay but but so they don't support
patterns
no
okay they've got to be the same as what
happens with vertex labels surely
well
the the difference is that
like i said that this is a position the
left-hand side is a position spec not a
vertex name and we don't have vertex
names
but it's presumably it's still useful to
be able to do things with patterns like
saying you know every even numbered
index make it red or something like that
yeah why wouldn't we support i mean
otherwise you know what so i mean i mean
like this like pattern and replacement
thing doesn't work
you so what does work what a tree
element label what left hand side is a
pattern that matches a position spec
and why can't x-blank match your
positions back
i just haven't done the replacement part
i don't understand what what would match
your position spec
i think the problem is
right
sorry what wait a minute what
what
inspect is
is the issue that this is like replace
part so he needs to give a pat a listy
sort of pattern that matches
oh
right
okay so so what happens if i say x blank
um
comma
x blank
comma triple blank
goes to this
anybody getting no what the heck's going
on nobody's getting framed here
why not
i'm totally confused what am i what
should i be seeing here if i if i put an
echo a regular rule
i'm i'm just irreducible
instead of rule
but that's not going to work because
it's going to evaluate the right side
yeah
right
well now why does that have a rule
delayed there i'm i'm just
because we're re optioning the same tree
a bunch of times
right you wanted the percent to be the
orig like percentage or whatever your
original your trading okay yeah okay
fine
now why is it labeled with one oh
because that no
because the x is one
right the x bound to one
right what is your equal to one because
it's
matching against the position it's like
replace part
oh i see i see so if this was
okay so let's say it's this and i said
this and that and i said slash semi x
not equal to y
then it will be much jollier
why is it matching one in those cases
isn't that because
because the first one is one right so
the x is one because they're all
children of one we'd say y arrow framed
of y or something
yeah okay
i'm surprised you can use the the bound
variables on the right hand side at all
i didn't even
intend to implement that
right maybe if you delete the first
blank again we'll get something more
interesting now
i see
okay yeah that makes sense
by the way you might want to give
examples like this in the documentation
for true element label
and rule delay should probably work
yeah definitely it should absolutely
shut i mean uh it's absolutely a bug
that
rule works but rule delayed the start
um
okay so let me just understand
uh
so tree element label the left hand side
is this now if i want to just say
okay so tree element label style
whoops
oh god this whole business up again
oh my gosh so i've got to do the all
arrow red right
okay but now if i say all arrow
and that's why
is there a good reason why
the
you know if it's not a rule why that
isn't just an implied all goes to
we would need a representation for just
this node
what do you mean just this node
if you so all of these options
specify the option for for
is actually it causes like a cascading
thing
where more lower options override
the options from the parent okay so
basically you're saying if you did tree
element label style goes to red inside
of a tree element
then
it would uh that particular one
would be red so long as this is really a
front and center top thing in the
documentation for tree element label
style it's probably okay
but it really has to be now how do i
make the backgrounds complete
backgrounds purple or something
that's tree element style
oh i see so if i say
okay so let me understand what this
is do i say background arrow whatever or
what do i say no you just give us that
um whoever's making that noise could you
stop please
okay
all right
okay so that's tree element style tree
element label style okay tree element
label function
um
come on the the
i think
yeah
okay
um
tree element label function
um
how could that be
okay
let's see so what does that do
what is it what are its arguments did we
go through this before i think we went
through this before what they are we
skimmed over it um
but we
didn't look at each one
individually okay
you were believed to be making guns
background noise my my thing said it was
on mute i just took it off oh it should
not have been me if it is i've got a
real problem here
okay okay okay
uh
the
um okay sorry but back to
um back to ian
what were you saying here
so the function takes one argument which
is the data
why doesn't it take okay so i don't
understand that why is it
true element label function so it only
takes the label
i don't understand what is this doing is
this making a label it's creating a
label
by default you use the data as the label
but what happens if i want to draw all
kinds of wild things in my in my nodes
of my tree how do i do that
either tree element label or tree
element label function
tray element label as if but why doesn't
i mean tree element if i want to draw
graphics
for example don't i need to know what
the coordinates are
not for the label
okay but if i want to draw look it's
vertex
shape function
i see you've got a tree element shape
function yep and a tree element shape
what does tree element shape do because
that's different that's the thing where
you just give it a graphics look at the
basic examples
but is there a vertex shape
for graphs
am i misremembering there's a vertex
shape function which is what one
typically uses because vertex shape
is just
right but you have to specify it for
each one
but not only do you have to specify it
don't you have to give
not for vertical
vertex shape you just give the
you just give the shape
vertex shape okay but if i want to
position them dimensions
right but the thing that it gives out
for vertex shape how does it know where
to put it
the vertical function knows where to put
it and the vertex shape function will
resize whatever you you gave for vertex
shape
but but but if i want to
i see so so i have to put it in in what
coordinate system
where's the center
of
the node
in other words if i draw a picture of an
elephant
and i want
the node to be at the position of its
you know the the end of its trunk or
something
how do i specify where
in the
vertex shape which is the elephant i
believe you would have to use tree
element shape function
for that
right they presume this just center
right centers your image on your
graphics on
wherever the quote-unquote vertex is
you know this documentation is
inadequate
avery this is something we need to take
up with those guys please
okay it's not explaining this
just not saying
growl
so what are you doing ian in the case of
trees
for tree element shape
tree element shape works the same as
vertex shape except for
you know the specification okay then
tell me what it does i mean then then
does that mean you know what it does
i mean it you specify the shape and then
it uses that as the vertex shape i know
that but how big is it and where does it
center it
that's handled by tree element shape
function
right so so there's another so what is
the automatic value of tree element
shape function is steven's question
yeah
i see
um
i mean
it's automatic
i presume the default is automatic and
then what effect what does that
effectively do if you specify a tree
element shape
that is my question yes
what's the answer how big is it what i
mean it's presumably then determined by
tree element size
entry element coordinates
okay but you need to be able to specify
that here
because tree element coordinates look
there's a func here tree element
coordinates is x y
yeah there's a separate tree element
coordinates option
that
specifies the value that would get fed
into that argument there no i understand
that but this is saying for example so
you're saying that between the vertex
shape what isn't defined there's one
thing that isn't defined here which is
where is x y
inside the picture of the elephant that
is data
i think you
can use inset for that
no but but where is it by default
it's centered at the
vertex coordinates
no no i'm asking where in the elephant
is it
where is the where is the
enter of the image
i would assume okay well but this needs
to be graphics to understand it's been
documented i mean you think it's the
default behavior of inset what is the
default behavior event set
i don't think i was saying that it's set
to change the placement
no i understand but it's probably
implemented within set and it probably
uses
i mean it's not obvious what the center
of the bounding box
would be
i'm i'm led to make some joke about
whether the elephant is still in the
room
but you understand what i'm saying where
is the
as you put the picture of the elephant
on that node
which part of the elephant is at the
position of the node
right and you're claiming it's the
center of the bounding box of the
elephant image is that
correct it seems to be the case okay
right so we should nail that down and
document it
and arguably and we should also document
in both tree element shape function and
uh vertex shape function how to use
inset to change that
it's completely not self-evident to me
that this will work
because
that may already be the case in the
graph documentation i'm not sure okay
well we should check but anyway
the point i'm making is there's a
certain region that has been cleared
for putting that vertex
i don't think that's true i don't think
that's true i think a a vertex is
you know determined and then
right it
puts something there right
yeah but the question is the arcs that
are coming into that vertex where do
they get
stopped
for example if that vertex is
transparent if the vertex shape function
is transparent
do the arc show up underneath it
um
yes i um
[Music]
that's the edge shape function and by
default we just use line
okay but so you're saying if i make a
transparent
vertex shape
function okay so here for example if i
go here
and i make the um
or if you just make the yeah if you do
tree elements shape function
all goes to none
true element shape all goes to none
shape function why why isn't it just
true element shape all goes to none
none is not a graphics or a
region
or an image
okay all right shape function goes to
none
that
is a bit weird
all right so right so the labels are a
little bit off of the
oh no of the actual node which i guess
makes sense right well i mean in this
case let's just reduce so that yeah so
if you use the automatic shape function
i center the labels inside the
the shape
which is not the default graph behavior
um so if you specify a non-default shape
function then it uses the same
label placement as graph
hey hold on why is tree element size
goes to zero not working here
because these things by design do not
resize when you resize the tree so that
you can
shrink the tree without making the
labels illegible
at the cost of making your labels
overrun each other
but i don't understand why wouldn't
that that's only with the default shape
function
i don't understand why wouldn't tree
element size just change the size okay
let's start off with something very
naive do tree of none real quick
right
you'll want to resize that
or probably tree of data comma none
put something in the payload
right now you'll want to resize that
yeah because by default graph has all
this space
what my claim is that if the tree
element size function interacted with
this
you now wouldn't be able to read that
label
i thought we were we were automatically
cutting down this um
the size
uh
i think it's something charles agreed to
at some point but i'm i don't know what
the status of the implementation is okay
so that's the thing for avery to go
chase
got it
okay
question here
um
well let's see what are we what are we
talking about here so you're saying
that unlike vertex size
so if i make an unlabeled tree here
unlabeled tree takes a tree
okay
now why isn't the vertex shape function
vertex size just working here just like
it does for normal graphic
for the unlabeled case um
why isn't that working that would be
fine
why isn't that working
if it's not if it hasn't been the
document if it hasn't been documented
yet right the coloring won't be no i
understand it isn't working either yeah
um yeah that should be pretty should
take options yeah yeah okay
all right okay but but so
i don't know whether i can do this it
might not work just say tree of
unlabeled tree
well well should it
if you specify tree element label inside
unlabeled tree
do you still get a label
label inside unlabeled tree yes sure
okay
i think that's a reasonable thing to do
okay so where were we here
where is there something still not
understood about tree element size
basically the trail element size option
only works with non-default shape
functions
and shapes
why why doesn't it work for the default
in the unlabeled case why doesn't it
determine the size of that node
could work in the unlabeled case that's
fine
okay but in the labeled case
you are saying
if we increase the size
um
that we shouldn't do anything
well wait a minute
um
what are we saying
you're saying if the
in the case of graphs
i'm saying what does it do
i'm saying in the labeled case we have a
fixed size which is just whatever the
size of the data okay but i don't think
that's right because look at what
happens with graphs
if we say vertex label goes labels go to
automatic
here
well actually if we did that with placed
right and put the a inside the the node
okay so the issue is this doesn't graph
doesn't have a way to do what tree is
doing
in a straightforward way of
uh like wrapping this
around the the label
and using that size
i mean
that's what i'm doing for tree
but you end up with something that's
just a fixed size
i'm confused does anybody like
christopher you're a user of these
things do you know what we're
what is the issue here is the issue that
the placed in the center
thing for graf is not being support
maybe we should try and get charles here
considering i'm saying place does not
interact with vertex shape
can we try and get charles
but christopher do you have an opinion
about this no i mean i these things are
always kind of mysterious to me i mean
part of it is that this sort of um
i think everything is kind of inset ish
like it's all graphics within graphics
well
i think what you've done here ian is
you've you've jumped beyond
you know you've gone to placed you've
got a thing where you're by default
doing a place inside the nodes of the
tree
and therefore you have a bunch of
different issues from graph
but the names of the options that you
have are the same as the names of the
questions placed alone would just
change where the label is i know it's
also the shape itself
depends on the label
by shape you mean the appearance of the
node
yeah like this is literally a framed of
the label so whatever size framed of
the label is
that is the size it will use
and tree element size can't i get it i
get it but you you've done that i mean
we could have a version of graph
that just labels its nodes in this kind
of very placed like this way we don't
have that right now you can get to that
point by setting a bunch of graph
options
right which
what i'm doing for trees is by having
the shape function
with a fixed size
right okay so we need to get
um charles and see what he has to say
about this for
graphs
because i think you know again the
question that i have design wise here is
that anything if what you're doing here
is always jumping beyond graphs with
different name structures here then
we're all good
but if there's something like tree
element size
where we would normally expect
you know you're saying let's hack i'm
saying it's only a problem with the
default shape function i'm saying if you
do any other shape or any other shape
function tree element size works exactly
as it does as vertex size does
hello
hi
we're looking at labeling in trees and
graphs
okay
and so ian has a bunch of options for
uh tree labeling that we are confused
about the relationship to graph labeling
so in particular tree element size
for a standard labeled tree
i don't understand this at all i mean
why does what is this doing this case
here
this is an example of tree element shape
well but that's also got tree element
size what does the large change the size
and see what it does
but it's the example here wrong because
it doesn't show it as big here resize it
well that example is very confusing
though i mean so
so
size is is
uh
well actually is there a way of setting
the size of like scaled or something or
like uh
how would you reproduce the behavior of
the vertices here that are not resizing
the graphic
so the tree so the shape function takes
three arguments one of them the third
argument is influenced by the size i'm
not quite sure how but it that's
it's influenced by the size and i'm
saying the default tree shape function
ignores it it just renders this the
shape as framed of the label
um charles can you comment on that
because you've got a vertex size that is
set externally
so to speak
whereas what what ian is doing is he's
shrink wrapping he's making the label
for every vertex of the tree every
element of the tree he's making it be
the framed of its payload
shrink-wrapped
white
what
and i think it that
i mean
i think that decision is even made more
based on the implementation of the
behavior of
you know that frame is an inset right
so an answer doesn't resize where
for a graph right if it's a disk
right it follow the normal behavioral
graphic when you resize it's precise
based on the you used actually the
viewport for the
window size
but if i wanted the behavior that ian
has for if i wanted to implement tree
with graph how would i do it
right so when you build the
so i believe the the the vertex shape
function that are using by default in
this case which you draw the frame with
the two inside this third argument of
insert should not be
should depend on the vertex size
right now i don't think it depends on
the vertex as it's probably fixed
automatic or such
yes that's correct
and my claim is that
if we made it depend on the image size
then
practically speaking every time you
resize the tree oh i don't think it's
the right thing for trees i don't think
it's the right thing i agree with you
because if you put if you've put the
payload in the label in in that name
there you don't want to get scrunched to
nothing probably
i mean you just can't scrunch it at all
i think yeah fine i mean i understand
but but so what i'm asking is
you know is there a way or should there
be a string name for example for
vertex shape function
that gives you this behavior for a graph
charles
a vertex shape function so that um
yes i mean we can do that
well it seems like a good idea to be
able to get because i've certainly
wanted that plenty of times where you
want
um you know i kind of want the two cases
one is a circle
uh you know one is a label and a circle
the other is the label in a rectangle i
think
and i think
in code we actually
let's see if you put in principle image
scale or you actually use the string
scale comma one and such it will give
you pretty much a similar behavior
can you can you send me the code
um
wait um i would try to write something
okay
but does it okay
so okay between ian
i just also want to point out that um
trees uses rounded rectangles for
non-leaves
yes
so you're saying we reproduce that
behavior as well
if if it's meant to be
yeah i just want to understand how to do
that i mean i'm
okay i mean i would find it useful i
would have found it useful many times to
just have a
you know vertex labels
that are
placed inside the nodes
you know the case which we have right
now of placing it
uh you know exterior to the nodes is
certainly useful but i think this
interior placement of the kind that
exists in tree is also useful and to be
able to switch between those as easily
as possible be really nice
i mean vertex labels arrow
and then something which says
uh you know do this enclosed label
business would be good i don't know
whether there's a way to do that
we we introduced um some plot theme like
um
named label where we actually do
something similar but not
was that again
what do you mean named label as in but i
mean what happens if i just say graph
namely
if i say vertex label arrow foo
i believe everything will be called foo
so unless we have some special case here
no no so what i mean so i mean the plot
team
name label right and he does that
right plot theme
there's a plot theme for graph
yes
we even have a meeting every time you
forget that we have the plot t4
well maybe we need a graph team maybe it
should be called graphing name label
a labeled yeah led
why doesn't this auto complete properly
um
you should actually
okay that's the thing for avery to go
tag down but that's not what i wanted i
want it inside the circles
can you take off the vertex
vertex label i don't understand what
happened there
wow i forget it every time as you say
charles i forget it every time
what happens if you use a really large
expression
yep you'll get out of
the circle
ugh
see why aren't we doing the thing with
the with the rounded rects there
yes
so yeah you requested that so we are
working with team on that so you will
okay you actually feed the frame
the size of the test
is this the most common case for plot
theme to be able to do this
is that the case one once all the time
no i mean it's depend of
you know the type of graph i mean at the
end it's not
the craft the size on the layout so it's
kind of the slot theme also change the
layouts
um no
no we currently don't change the layout
probably could
yes
um
i do forget it every single time
and arguably it should be called graph
theme
and how do we document this
is it in graph
um yes it's at the end of the
the bottom of the details there
that's incomprehensible
that's just freaking incomprehensible
that's freaking incomprehensible just
show here
that you say plot theme arrow these
things
right
plot three arrow theme possible forms
for theme are blah blah blah blah
see what i'm saying yep oh it's just
incomprehensible
it's like you have to know what what's
possible
what's that what's incomprehensible
okay graph feature themes affect the
plots feature themes include but then we
see possible settings include
common-based themes color feature themes
plot font feature themes and size
feature themes let me say this feature
theme it's just very indirect
right but i mean usually people will
want to set you know one of the feature
themes and then you know they might want
to tweak some
settings with us right you can specify
multiple themes right and then then you
should write that out plot theme arrow
quotes theme plot theme arrow list this
this
you know make it make a make a table of
that it's not comprehensible as you have
it
sure i mean it'd be actually great if we
can rename that you know graph team and
have a page and you know
document it more more in detail an
example what do you think do you think
we should do that i think we should do
that
yes especially now that we introduced
for um we are producing team right for i
think is
data set and search that would be nice
all right i think we should do that i
mean you've got to continue to support
this one but i think you should do that
but also that documentation right there
is just inadequate please
but i don't think that's different from
how plot famous documented then that's
inadequate as well
take a look at
plot theme
clock theme itself or plot yes yes
it's
it's a scheme we picked to document it
we can review it with roger
this is this is this is better because
it's much more explicit
that other thing was too short it was
incomprehensible
it's
okay in any case it should it should be
expanded but let's not let's not go
there okay so have we established
where we were talking charles before you
got here about
when you specify
something to be the plot label
you mean shape
shape
and it's a picture of an elephant and i
kept on asking
where does the node position go in the
elephant in other words the fourth
argument to inset
am i making sense
um
yes
and how does that get classified now
maybe your placed specifies that
and how should placed work in trees
it
works
so are you talking about the
so place is for labels are you thinking
about the shape
why the shape is related to shape
function the shape of a note a little
confused there
well i mean in the end one's going to
draw something at the node and it's a
shape you can factor that into
a shape and a label
but in the end you're going to draw
something there and i'm asking let's say
the shape is the shape of an elephant
and i'm asking where does the
coordinates of the node go in the
elephant
right so in term of
graph and vertex shape
right
the shape it's you know essentially the
centroid or the center of the shape
which match
the vertex coordinate of the node right
is that found by the bounding box
white
yes
okay and because it's controlled by
pretty much insert right and then it's a
second argument of insert where it's
essentially centered we must just center
where for labels we use place and then
the placement specifications tell you
where to place it
okay
have you guys ian and charles have you
looked through this list in detail and
compared it to the to the graph case
not together
i think you guys should
i mean i i may be missing things here
um
because i think that there's some
consistency that we need to check
tree edge label so that's the equivalent
of edge label
so you've defined this notion of a tree
edge yeah
and so rather than being attached to an
edge since we don't have edges
this is the same thing it's at a
position
and it
applies to the
parent edge at that position
um
said again i'm sorry i got distracted by
something here could you could you say
that again please right so you're not
labeling
an actual edge
like in graph you're specifying a label
at a position
same as with
the tree element options and it affects
the parent edge of that node
ah
because in a graph you'd specify it by
the
uh you know
source and sink
names on the edge that's how you
represent an edge whereas here okay so
this is is this the incoming or the
outgoing edge
oh so it's specified in the node
containing one
and so it's for the incoming edge to
that node
why do you do it that way
rather than the outgoing oh i see
because there's a unique incoming node
but there are multiple outgoing nodes
yep is that the argument
so if we if we go dag at some point then
that will no longer work
right if we if we tried to generalize
this to dags
we could have two incoming nodes could
we not
got incoming edges
i still think dags are just graphs
i mean yeah we shouldn't i mean what you
mean is that we shouldn't extend it to
that i guess
yeah all right whatever okay
okay this i understand what this is
doing tree edge it's a pity that it
can't clue one in
that it's the incoming edge
in the name you get what i'm saying
because that seems a bit unobvious to me
no you see this isn't good enough
no this isn't this really isn't good
enough we can oh i see as well as that
of any subtree so you're saying it's the
label
so same as with like style if you just
say red it's for the root node but you
can also have
positions matching a pattern and have
styles for subjects right but this is
basically the external label of a
subtree labeled on its incoming edge
so i think it's got to say that more
clearly that this is if you think about
it as the
label for the edge that feeds the
subtree
that's what this is
right
will be a short name for that if we
wanted to give us the short name if we
um is tree label too dangerous
since it's absolutely way too old it's
the whole sub tree being labeled yeah
it's it's too dangerous because it's
also not clear that it's a it's a label
on halfway up
the edge that lead that feeds the
subtree so to speak
anybody got any ideas for this
um
it's i christopher anybody
but we want to call it like the
root label because we're we already have
our own
i'm trying to think of you know within
tree linguistics would we say it's the
stem label
i don't think we talk about tree stems
anywhere but
we're branching i don't think we do but
i think that the stem is a very good
name for it in the sense that it is
clear that that is the thing
the stem
is not the root so to speak
well
branch what about tree branch label
no because that doesn't get you the
point the stem what's nice about stem
is the stem leads to something
there's one stem
whereas a branch there are many branches
okay okay i missed something can we back
up a bit what exactly are we trying to
name we're trying to name the thing that
is the incoming okay so the point is
that
wherever i've got an example here yeah
calling it the parent edge of the root
node which is not
succinct
right so here the basic point is
what do you actually label here where
does where is that label the o and e
associated with the answer is
it's associated with
this sub tree here it is the feeder for
that sub tree that's where the label
goes it goes on to the stem which feeds
that sub tree
i see
and just saying it's on the edge is
confusing because like well which edge
there are lots of edges here
um
but right it's
oh
um
right
um
you're right it's not the edge right
because it's the thing that leads into
the one two three
right so so theoretically right can can
you give an edge label to
zero
and would that just be sort of hover
above zero what would that do it
wouldn't render until you used the tree
as a subtree of something
i see okay
so this is so tree
edge label
that's simply invisible which is rather
confusing and i hope you've documented
that clearly
uh i'll clarify it
yeah
um this is a hard thing to name i think
it should be called tree stem label
tree stem shape function
yeah
tree stem this is the tree stem this is
the stem of the tree
and a root doesn't have a stem
i claim
which is why you don't see it if you
specified a stem label
for that
root node
it's just buried in the ground so to
speak
tree fertilizer label
that's a more meta
thing for the tree it's not the this is
a tree which has grown
okay
not a not a potential tree what do other
people think about tree stem label what
do you call the parent that contains a
sub tree do we call it parent or is
there some other term
yeah the parent
but this is
yeah
oh parent edge label that's the
terminology i use in the notes is the
parent edge of the root node
well but in principle the parent can
have many edges i mean it's kind of
obvious you're talking about the edge to
the to this particular child but right
because it's an option of the child
right
yeah but that's you're right that the
parent edge
i see it's the the edge to the parent
exactly right
it's kind of like analogous to source
link
and totally different
yes it is it is
parent edge label is not bad
i mean it is nice you know stem you have
to think of it to realize it's an edge
yeah i think i like parent edge
yeah i do too
is there are there other things yeah we
have parent tree right
that's a um that's a thing
how would that work
no we don't that doesn't mean nothing
what do we have
do we have anything that is
apparent associated with trees we'll use
the string parent when we get tree
relative
okay but i mean parent edge label
what is parent list what is that anybody
know what parent list is
uh that's a front-end option
so
before we had the inherited associations
and the appearance
object
then
you could set an option
which set in a list which included
parrot list which meant don't completely
override
the options from set at a higher level
add whatever is here to whatever is
you know the style settings that are set
at the higher level so that's what
parent list is for
okay
but so are we bothered by the fact that
there's a tree function that doesn't
start with tree
i think not terribly bothered
comments from other people oh i thought
we were suggesting tree parent edge
label i don't think so i think it would
just be parent edge label
what do other people think
i kind of like parent edge label i think
it's good that it includes the word edge
because if someone is looking for
something in the documentation that's
the key word they're going to use
right
i think pretty much all the other
instances of using parent as
a symbol name are related to that legacy
front-end behavior we have parent
notebook but
otherwise obviously parent directory is
something else yeah which is but it's
very related right it's conceptually
it's it's visualizing the file system as
a tree are we going to run into the
problem
with edge label again that you might
want parent edge label to work for
things other than trees but it might not
be compatible behavior that you want in
both cases like a graph
yeah it could work in a dag
yeah only just
notebook what's the edge label of a
notebook
um
i think we should do parent edge label
i think
yeah i think so i mean as i say stem is
probably too whimsical and obscure what
do other people think about that
do we kill stem
so to speak
i think so okay
boy with all of this emphasis on
anyway never mind stem
okay all right
let's see if we can hit something else
here are we are we done with these do
you think ian
um
we didn't look at style function or size
function
label function
[Music]
uh
we did look wait a minute style function
for what
um
there's tree element style function
there's tree uh
edge style function
right i thought we did look at that oh
we looked at style but not style
function
okay what is style function style
function is not style
because it is taking arguments that are
what
and what else
that's it
why are we bothering with this if if
you've got if look in the case of this
case of you know you have
style you know i have a tree where lots
of things have a lots of things have b
and you want to have different styles i
get it but why
given that we've got to in a tree as
opposed to a graph we've got to use the
pattern representation we've got to use
the rules to specify what the tree
element style is you can't just say tree
element style are a red because it only
affects one one element
so you've got to say tree element style
goes to
you know
a blank goes to whatever blah blah blah
blah blah or all goes to whatever so i
don't understand why we need a function
here because
this is how we this is what we discussed
earlier the rule is for a position spec
not for the data
this allows the style to depend on the
data
do other people i get it but i mean does
that clear from the name and is that is
that the same usage analogy with
no it's not the same usage analogy with
graph because graph
works directly with vertex names
i don't get it
anybody else
understand
look
vertex style is there there's no vertex
style function is there
no
no it's not really needed like like you
see right we can use pattern
volt2 and then we apply that so right
you don't really need a function
right so the reason that you need a
function here is because the pattern is
a pattern on the location not on the
data
right
right
well welcome to supplied
because supplied would deal with this
maybe wouldn't it
if the pattern involved supplied if not
supplied could be supported by style
function
and it could be supported by the
right-hand side could be supplied and
you could put in things like the
position spec and in addition to the
data or and potentially other things
yeah exactly but that could be part of
tree element style it wouldn't need to
be
another style element the supplied is
not a style
supplied is for functions
well we haven't defined that we've also
said supplied can be the right-hand side
of a rule
no
well we've certainly discussed that we
discussed the need
the idea that we were discussing most
recently for that was environment
variables
okay
yeah and all of that was going
well maybe we should add this to the
agenda for the next discussion of
environment variables replied which was
going to happen today so
so dev or avery sorry uh make a note of
these last few minutes and copy
and prepare them for me to add to that
agenda yep
i can do that i'm sorry i missed the
thing earlier
um
all right so what are we going to do
with this
add it experimentally in this version
i mean everything related is
experimental still and which is good
because we're still breaking things from
version to version so
yeah
all right well i mean how do other
people feel about this do you think it's
okay or i i think it's a little bit over
complicated and i think it can be ground
down a bit
again
i don't have an alternative way to
do the task that you want i understand i
understand style things based on the
data
all right well let's put this in like
this okay anything else to look at here
um don't think so
all right let's have a quick look at
these other things
this first thing here that danny is here
for
um
okay what's this about
so this is the discussion we had last
week about position largest and smallest
um
we got into a bit of a quagmire with
trying to figure out how to handle the
second argument of position
largest or smallest because we want it
to give back a rank and the structure
there
is the information's non-trivial and
it's useful but the basic use case uh
that we originally started with was give
me the position of the maximum value and
maybe just the first position of it and
danny proposed that maybe we should just
split this into two functions one that
is more descriptive and gives us
multiplicity and rank and one that just
says give me the position of the max
value
like we have
first position
already
haven't you okay so what's the proposal
here
you're saying position first largest and
position largest or something
danny yeah first position largest or
something like that well you've written
down here position first logic okay fine
seems like it should be first position
or strikes it's like first position
yeah
okay
but
okay so you're saying that would give
the analog i mean first position
gives
see the problem is what happens if you
want okay first position
just
establishes
oh god it still gives it a list oh
that's because it's an actual position
spec yep
uh what would you propose first position
largest does then
yeah it's tied into a list doesn't it
unless it takes a level spec
or unless it doesn't take a little speck
i mean
um that was definitely danny
yeah no i i implicated
implicated that was my chair squeaking
explicated
um
fair enough
uh
who needs video when you can get the
audio posture postural data by audio
um
anyway never mind
uh
that would have been a thing before
video conferencing
anyway
um
okay so the issue is
the case where you're getting
what is all this stuff
a different function
okay but what are you proposing for this
other thing
well
what i'm proposing is whatever it takes
to not derail this again
so last time
a position largest got into this whole
discussion of well most of the time what
people want is just the first position
of the largest element and it's unique
etc etc and that's not what position
largest was designed or intended to deal
with okay so what is position largest
what was position largest doing
previously it's giving
the
all the positions
of
the largest rank element
and if you ask for two for example then
it gives all positions
in in separate sub-lists corresponding
to the two
largest in rank elements
the two largest families of elements yes
better way of saying it
okay so i think one of the issues is
does that two mean
just give me the first two in some
electrical graphic order of positions or
does it mean give me the first two
families la the latter because i know it
you can already trivially do the other
with take largest in index
we want something
that that is substantially more
difficult to get
without you know us writing it in
internal code which is what i did
we don't want something that's trivial
to get and and
no new purpose
okay i understand but so the issue is if
we do this then when the default case of
one in that second argument we've got a
heavily encrusted object
right that's the basic point here this
here
yeah it's a double list
right so the default case it's not
double it's triple list
it's a triple list
what what the heck is that what why is
position it's a nested list
okay why does position logic not work
with one argument uh because i didn't
make it work with one argument okay but
that will be the same as this right okay
is that correct yes
unless we want an operator form for it
does it have an operator form
i think it does but i don't remember for
certain well but it seems like the one
argument case is way more useful yeah i
mean it seems like if the one argument
case can be used a lot more then that's
worth more than an operator form for a
rather obscure multi-argument absolutely
absolutely okay so the argument so to
speak is remove the operator form if
there is one
and get it to work with one arg
yes but now what you're saying is
the position logic
hold on sorry sorry what do you what do
the layers of that list mean so is there
so
is it internet list
yeah go ahead each corresponds to a
separate family in order
or so sorry but i mean the list of lists
of two there right so is the i guess
it's the same as the one above but like
if the inner
so so
the the two though is not part of
position spec like position it's just
correct
correct it's just an element it happens
to be a family with just one element
i understand
it's not a position spec yes
that's because there's no level spec is
that is that right
i'm
not sure because i'm always confused by
such things yeah i mean this doesn't
look great at all right
well it would be a triple list that's
the point this thing here will be a
triple list
we don't want a triple list
yeah
but that's that's the whole point called
indices largest
but that's so totally obscure
look people are going to think of this
as position largest that's the name
they're going to think of so the
question is
how do we deal with encrustment yeah the
first question is i mean i i would argue
that
okay the layers of you know there are
three different potential layers of list
there's one layer of list to to turn the
two into a position spec compatible with
like extract and position and so on
the next layer of list is the
family
yeah size then this right equal size
then the
the the third level of list is is i
asked for the top three tying families
right i would argue that the last one
is a niche thing i mean i understand
that part of the reason it's there is to
differentiate it and take largest but
it's i think it's just not that common
and adding an extra layer of list for in
all cases when 90 of the time
you know you only want the the number
one family
so you're saying get rid of that
argument entirely well that's the second
argument have it be a one argument
function and
i myself don't think that's the right
thing to do but i'm willing to do it
i would check uh with gosha though
since this kind of is in the take
largest family and you know
we we okay but hold on is there any way
out of this could we you know it seems
wrong to have the default case
i mean there is a hacky way out of this
that we've used for some functions
like seller automaton uses this
which is that the default
okay this is this is hakola
hakka haku
right there's no default argument
there's no default value for the
secondary the default no no but we could
have the default value be this oh
that's what we've done in some other
cases
now tell me what exactly that means
because
it means
the opposite of what's intuitive based
on the way it's do not pretend that this
is a level spec
because this function will not take a
level spec it's not that's something
that's way
outside i know this is a family
difference
okay that's yet another reason why this
syntax is bad i mean it's already used
for cellular autonomy so with cellular
automata when you give it the number of
steps you do if you just say like you
run it for 10 steps it'll give you the
first 10 steps if you ask for like
list of list of list of 10 then it will
only give you the state after 10 steps
with no extra lists around it
but you realize exactly how horrifying
that sounded i forgot
there weren't that many let's see there
was an exaggerated number of lists there
but it is it is wonderful i think there
is actually behavior at three levels
this is a hacky weird way to get to
what's not so bad is that if the one
argument far form gives things that are
one level less deep than the two
argument form
and if you need a two argument form that
represents the one argument use
automatic instead of this list one thing
yeah well that might be right that's
what i thought you were going to suggest
yeah yeah that's not so terrible
yeah i kind of agree because you know
you've got two arguments there it's
hardly as if you don't know that you
gave two arguments exactly right so run
that back bob
okay so
the two argument form is exactly what
you have i think except unless we want
to make them proper position specs i
don't know about that but the one
argument form is the same thing as
giving it one and then sequence that at
basically you know you drop the outer
list because
you know okay
maybe maybe think of it as first instead
of that
yeah first sure yeah yeah um yeah first
okay so
so that would be a case where
you're just giving a singly nested list
a single list of of integers basically
right right right because you know it's
always length one when it's okay in the
one way but no aren't are we aren't we
still actually giving positions
well that's another question yeah yeah
this is assuming we don't switch to
business respects which is the second
right so in this list of three different
levels of list we have we're basically
saying that the third level of list
families level is only included in the
two argument form in the one argument
form it just calls first and it just
gets rid of that whole level of list
well i think we've got to give positions
backside i don't know do can we get away
with even though this is a one level
function
even for first position
there is an argument i mean that that
will be a first first position function
that just gives naked indices
first position does take electrical spec
okay yeah i believe it does it yeah
i mean each each of these is a part spec
right
right so so if you did possibly
you would get
just the second one if you did part of
the list eight three you'd get the
eighth one and the third one
right i mean i feel like the problem is
just that is more they use the word
position
right and every other position function
gives extract specifications
right and this isn't
right so so you're right and i
i object to something being called
position blah when it's not giving
positions right
i mean i did not understand that this
only worked on flat lists
you would prefer part largest
uh
sure
or index largest uh yeah i think
somebody suggested that
it's just really really really obscure
i guess the question is
why why is it important that we strip
out the the outer list for you know not
have these be
i mean well i guess this only works at
level one but
the position spec level of list yeah
well because because the minimal case
then is this right this is then
although that list comes from a
different source than the list the
source we're talking about here
that says that the minimal thing if i in
this thing here that tie the 8 3 tie
there it's going to look like this
the minimal case is going to look like 8
3 like that
that's if you strip a level
that's if you strip the family level yes
right if the one argument case the
function yes
just to throw one minor monkey wrench in
here we do actually have a position
named function that doesn't give
position specs and that's position index
gives parts x for the position
but i don't
yeah
it's
it's the one that makes an association
of uh yeah it tells you where
where things appear in the list
wow
this is actually i think a pretty useful
function
function yeah
but it is but its notion of position is
naked position numbers
right yeah i don't suppose naked
position largest is going to cut it god
i wonder what the seo would do for that
um
that's
the behavior that i would think makes
sense for position largest returning
position specifications and you can give
a level just like position
um right
yeah that may indicate that that we have
the wrong name for the function
i don't think we really want to go with
specs level specs what how what the heck
does the level mean because you've got
to be comparing listen there's only one
level at which you can do comparisons
because typically with most comparison
functions by the time you've got
a higher level
it's very unlikely that the comparison
function is going to work
you can imagine doing it at level two
like lit level list two
right yes but but then the largest level
matrix
yes you could do that but then you
couldn't do it at level one
right i guess so what well what do you
mean you couldn't well because because
you've got a bunch of vectors as you
okay i mean if somebody really wants to
do that they can either use map
or
you know define a custom
function for doing the comparisons
yeah depending on what exactly they want
to do
right yeah i mean also i think we
definitely go back to the earlier
statement though i think we definitely
do not want it this function doing
crystal ball magic to figure out oh you
gave me a matrix that means i should
actually be yeah no it's completely
level
i mean having it you know being at a
rate depth of minus one
is a perfectly sensible thing nice
well what if like i don't know i i don't
know too much about how a rate up works
but what if for example you have a
ragged array does that suddenly mean at
the end of the year
higher depth is only yeah the
raggedness
breaks your comparison function i
haven't talked about this and it's not
documented but you can give it a
optional comparison function like length
well the third argument the comparison
function yeah i it would have to
actually be rigged slightly um you know
ordering of length of slash slash or
hash hash or whatever right well i mean
right you're right
right but if you used say
yeah well i suppose if it's always doing
things at level one and you have a
matrix rate then you could give it
vector-less or something yeah
yeah maybe maybe just one other point i
mean just because we mentioned position
index i have wanted the the like level
two version of position index but of
course they can't have it because of
this problem that uses positions instead
indices instead of positions
so
just for what it's worth
i mean as in this function maybe one day
we want to give this function a level
spec too
yes
and then we would have to have it do
this thing about having different forms
for if there's a level spec
and of course i mean the thing is if you
do give that extra level of list you
know for position specs
you know it's slightly uh it's slightly
annoying but it's very easy to get
around it's just part of a one or
something like something like that
but yeah the converse is is impossible
right if it doesn't give those then
there's nothing you could do
i have a name to propose
about location largest
no it doesn't carry any position
connotation
no
no i mean then we've got a whole giant
family of location
locators so to speak all right
right yeah so so richard put in chat
basically what what would be my into you
know intuition about what a position
largest does i mean irrespective of what
it's
you know the default level is right you
basically
get positions at a specific level and
then you extract them and compare them
which i don't think basically
well right
maybe another way of framing this
function that the richard has here is
it's basically it's position but without
the
second argument you know the object that
you're looking for spec and the implicit
object you're looking for is just max of
you know at the correct level and so on
yeah i don't think this is the function
we want i think the function we want is
the one
i mean there is this question of what
exactly the return type should be
but i think we want something that looks
at a
a single list or
or at the level one of whatever it's
given
look if we're doing the illusion for
families we can do the illusion for
levels as well
well i mean with levels you can just map
the thing
no i'm saying
you mean to get different levels yes
does that work
well no you can make it work
no but if you don't you can't
if you've got the max of of if i have a
matrix i know the max position and list
in row 1 is 12 and the max position and
row 2 is 15 i don't know which is the
max of the whole matrix
yeah i'm maybe i'm not understanding oh
you're trying to find the max of the ho
the position of the max no the ij
j position
got it got it got it got it okay so look
it seems to me once we cross the bridge
of a lighting a list
and particularly given the future
potential for for enhancing position
index to have a level spec
i kind of think that the right thing to
do here is to have position largest
not return the family list by default
and
i'm kind of thinking not return the
position spec list by default
now okay because the thing about that is
i think that would actually be quite
useful but it's also horrible you know
it would also have been quite useful in
position which of course doesn't do that
so
yes it's sort of well actually i'm sorry
because the default the default level
spec for position isn't it some infinity
head zero true or something like that
anyway so it's actually never mind
the default can't be that
but i think it's kind of wrong that it's
infinity heads are true but that's a
different issue well i mean we could
conceivably have a function list
position for example
that just gives the thing you want 99 of
the time which is the position of
something in a list
and we could you know as an extension we
could allow it to do some other function
thing but if we had list position which
i agree would be
you know i agree because i've wanted
this a gazillion times
yeah i mean with with position i i do
like every time i i use position and
like quote unquote real code like robust
code you know i always feel guilty and
then i have to put you know this head
zero false you know level one or
maybe we should have a thing called list
position that just does that thing
just gives you the position of something
in a list
that's it it's two arguments
yeah
it is maybe it takes
a position at level one with the heads
goes to false
that's correct
just so that's a one-liner in terms of
implementation yes because that's how we
would implement it
okay
sure
danny don't say
first list position largest
first this position largest
yeah
right now we need to make one of those
tables of you know well we've covered
this functionality so now we need to
have uh you know phil's gap oh no no not
the e-tie table
i think that was actually my table oh
yeah
all right list position i think we
should consider i've i've wanted
something like that for forever now
position largest
i kind of think we should go ahead well
i'm just going to say if we're going to
have a list position then maybe we
should have this should be let's
position largest
yes because it's not a bad idea
in which case
okay but maybe also i mean
i i feel like
okay
it might still i think it is still some
somewhat useful functionality if you can
get the max position of a matrix
that's crazy to have another function
for that i mean position largest the
question is how bad do we feel about the
thing about you know drop families okay
so the idea would be that the default
structure position largest is automatic
automatic or something or automatic i
don't know none or something and that
none is a level spec that means just
don't use levels and therefore don't
return
uh the the position like i mean that's
an interesting idea for other functions
actually that is an interesting idea no
no no no i think the third argument
would be list one
and it's the automatic that is saying
i just want the first thing without
having an extra layer of list no but i
think the point is if you say list one
then you have to return the you know yes
be consistent with list two and this
three and then it returns a list
for each position spec right the point
of writing none is that it's not even
going to return a position spec it's
just gonna return a name i'm saying if
the second argument controls
whether you
just take the first
the the list for the first rank or
whether you have a a list
of lists for each rank
no but we say the the second argument is
the family the third argument is the
thing we're describing as the position
spec okay so i think the interesting
idea here which just occurred
is the idea of a none
uh level spec
okay because we could even imagine that
for position itself what does that mean
it means are you talking about the input
or the output student i'm talking about
the input i'm talking about the input so
here's what i'm suggesting okay so what
i'm suggesting is it's a little weird
perhaps
i'm suggesting that in the case here if
i say this position of that a common
none
okay i'm suggesting that
what's that
none as a level spec that's the level
spec yes you should to make this example
clear you should make 2a put two a's in
the list otherwise it's ambiguous what
you're about to write
yeah okay
so what i'm gonna say is
that returns the list one comma three
okay
that is not crazy in my opinion
i'm
hard-pressed to understand how this
operates as a level spec
the whole point is it's the whole point
is it's not it isn't
it is a there is no level that we're
talking about we're just looking at the
top level and we're going to ignore
the
i mean it's a way it's a level it's
level one with a different output type
okay basically yeah i mean i think i
think the point of this
i i'm still totally sold on this but i
mean i think it seems like the point of
this is just that there are a bunch of
functions that for the sake of
generality
you know uh
return return uh position specs but
where a lot of the time you're just
giving it a level one list
right and so you know it would be nice
if you didn't have to
to write all these extra list things
around them
okay
i think this is an interesting idea to
have a
maybe none isn't the right thing but to
have
a named level
that is a that is an unpeeling level so
to speak
that says don't give the explicit
position
well it has to be something like none
because it's only going to work at the
first level
it's basically saying if this function
were not where if this function were a
function that didn't accept a level spec
what would you uh what would what would
you want yeah
well i mean part of our problem is not
does it accept the level spec position
largest i mean but the naming the fact
that position is in the name
okay but but listen i think a study
should be done of other functions that
have a level spec and whether this
non-idea will be useful for a bunch of
them
yeah i can take an inventory of those
and see
where we're gonna return to issues at
least
well another question is if you know
there's separately this idea of position
list i mean maybe this replaces position
list but
or list position although although this
position would also have the heads that
are false and stuff but and the
different default but
um
i mean if we had this
is the reason not to have list position
have take two arguments and you know its
default is none head zero false but it
can take other things and i mean at that
point it's basically just a replacement
for position
yeah that gets
it's not it gets a little bit confusing
but also there's the question of is it
worth it
um
all right so
we need to look at this position versus
looking at a none argument for position
which i think is probably a more general
approach
it's more general but i think that if
i mean
yeah i think that's that's the right
thing but also just as a no i mean if if
we had this concept in version one then
i would argue positions should have
different default settings that's a
different issue probably so
yes
but
uh it's a no time machine problem
right um
what does automatic mean in this setting
if none is the one that strips
strips
strips the position spec
yeah automatic is the one that strips
the family list
well but maybe by the same logic that we
chose none instead of automatic maybe
you should be mine
that makes sense
so uh this automatic as it is now
we we would simply return
a
single list of
integers
and those integers would correspond to
the top
um
the the top friendly positions top rank
yeah
right
okay um
all right let's examine this none idea
which it should have been an idea 30
years ago whatever but just only
justified
um
that's the nature of these things
uh
um
you know let's examine that as a
possibility
and other things
and then
until we go from that and maybe this
becomes position largest of the least
common non-common noun as the default
makes sense
i'm not sure about that second the first
none the second large amount yeah i
agree i think it might be better as
automatic
yeah
yeah that has a clear unambiguous
meaning
all right let's have a think about this
has to think about that none thing
and we should probably wrap up for now
okay so nick you're going to look into
some of that yep i'll do something
okay and i got that i was supposed to
stay for something else here okay
and nick you'll let me know what what
you find out and
[Music]
that'll give me some idea what to do
with position largest at least
i think we're very close on position
largest there's only a question how
these defaults work
okay
i'm i'm a little bit um less clear on
the idea of how we're going to retrofit
but using it in position largest i
understand now
right i don't know how the retrofit
works
okay so nick i'll follow up you'll
follow up with me and we can uh
at least i can get it into position
largest in the next i don't know a week
or two or whenever
this is not for 13 1 i assume
i don't think it can be this function
okay so we'll we'll
i'll try to yeah we'll try to work this
out and maybe i can put it in after the
code freeze so it won't go into thirteen
one
yeah
sounds reasonable to me
any anything else for right now
nope okay thanks guys thanks